[Captions by Y Translator]
Today, we're going
to be taking a look
at a very old-fashioned way
to heat up a fire, hot enough
that it can melt metal.
[Music]
I'm here again
with my friend Joseph,
and we've got some leather
and some other supplies,
and Joseph is going to teach us
how to make a Bellows
that can heat up a fire
hot enough to melt metal.
>> Is that right?
>> Yes.
>> Very cool.
>> Yes, and this is
for an upcoming project
where we're actually going
to try making iron from scratch,
just like the Vikings did.
>> But one of the key points
for that is you need to get
a fire just unbelievably
hot to do that, right?
>> Yes.
Well, less hot than you think.
Because when you make iron,
you actually never
actually melt it.
Melting iron like that
was invented way way way
after we had swords and stuff.
>> And how hot are we going for?
>> About a little
over 2,000 degrees.
>> Over 2,000 degrees.
>> Okay, so not that hot.
>> And how long does it have to go?
>> Like seven hours.
>> Seven hours.
>> That is a long time.
That would take probably several
propane tanks worth of fuel,
but we're not going
to use propane.
We're going to
be using charcoal.
>> Yes, and cheeseburgers to power
the human powered Bellows,
or maybe not cheeseburgers.
>> Here's the basic idea.
We've got a bunch of leather,
and we're going to cut
and sew that into a shape
that lets us control the flow
of air heating up a fire.
So let's look at some
of those supplies we've got.
First off, a Russian
olive tree,branch.
>> Yes, and the thing
that's important about this one
is it's got nasty spikes
on it, all over the place.
>> What?
It's a fairly durable,
rigid spike and
it's quite sharp,
and this is one of the tools
we're going to be trying to use
to poke holes in the leather.
> So we're going to give a try
and see how it goes,
trying to make holes
with this to sew it together.
I mean, we're
thinking primitive here.
So no sewing needle,
that would be cheating.
>> We might cheat.
>> Just a little bit
if this doesn't work at all.
We'll try some of the primitive,
and then for the sake of speed,
we'll probably cheat.
Speaking of cheating,
these are very
nicely round sticks,
and I did not harvest these
off of a tree myself.
I harvested these from Walmart.
But for this having a perfectly
straight smooth stick,
that's really not important
for what we're going to use.
These are going
to be sort of handles
at the top of our Bellows
that we can open and close
as we manipulate them.
Now, we have a piece of antler.
I don't know if that's
as pointy as the thorns,
but it's probably
a lot stronger.
>> Yes, probably.
Bamboo.
Why do we have bamboo?
>> Bamboo is for the air pipe.
So we're going to have
a bag made out of leather
with two sticks of the top
that you pinch closed.
So you open up
for air this way,
then you close and push down.
But the air needed somewhere
to go out to go to the fire,
and that's what this is for.
>> So this is what we use
to direct the air.
Yes.
Just where we want it.
Now, bamboo will burn.
What's the strategy
for preventing that?
>> We will coat the tip in clay.
>> And then of course,
we have leather.
This is quite
a bit of leather,
and again, we cheated.
We did not tan
the leather ourselves.
So we have quite a big sheet
of really nice tough leather.
This is actually more industrial
than it needs to be like...
>> Yeah.
>> This is pretty thick,
pretty high quality, tanned hide,
and this is really a lot nicer than we need.
>> But, if it's super robust,
and that means we can use
it for a long time.
Yeah.
This is artificial sinew.
In the old days,
they would take tendons
from a dead animal,
but like the cow,
we didn't want to do that.
So this is a replicated stuff
made of just
some very fine fibers,
and coated with wax.
We'll probably use this
for most of the sewing.
So what's going
to be our first step?
>> First step, we need
to measure out exactly
what we want the Bellows
to look like,
and that's going to be dependent
on how much leather we have.
>> We're going to do
four side panels,
and two bottom panels.
The goal is to make to Bellows.
>> Yes.
And I think that's
because that way,
as you're pumping air,
you can always have
one pushing air in,
while the other
one is refilling.
>> Yes, and one,
it does two things,
it regulates the airflow,
and it also prevents the air
from the Bellows from sucking
air in from the fire,
which would burn it,
and cause problems.
>> All right, we're going to use
this very authentic primitive
technology chalk marker.
So let's make four rectangles.
>> Four rectangles.
the sides,
and you are saying we want
them about one cubit long,
and not quite a cubit tall.
Cubit, if you don't know,
is the distance from your elbow
to the tips of your fingers.
I don't know the exact scale,
but of course, as you get taller,
your arms also get
a little bit longer.
So let's instead
of the full qubit.
Let's just take it
down by a few inches.
>> Maybe the top of the top
of the first knuckles.
Very precise caveman
style measuring here.
[Music]
To save time however,
we're going to use
this pair of industrially
large sharp scissors.
[Music]
We've got four rectangle-ish
pieces of leather cut out.
>> Yes.
So now we want a bottom piece
that you had a flat.
I'm thinking just kind
of like almond-shaped.
>> Yes, almond-shaped would be
just about right.
>> Eyeball almond
that goes out and then...
>> football.
>> You take the marker.
>> Okey-dokey.
>> I'm just going to take
this piece of leather,
and hold it, sort of up
in this curve shape,
and then you can just draw
along that curve,
and then we'll know
it's the right length.
[Music]
So we've got a bunch of pieces.
We now need to
sew them together.
>> So, the order to do that in...
I figured we'll just sew
along the sides, to make kind
of a envelope shape,
and then put the bottom on.
>> Joseph is going
to harvest a thorn.
He just slapped me with this.
Fortunately, the part
that hit me did not seem
to have any thorns on it.
>> Yeah.
>> How are we doing on stabbing
a hole in leather with a thorn.
>> Well, I've broken three or
four points off of this thorn.
>> Now, I actually did stab a hole
in this leather with one
of these thorns before,
but I'm now struggling to do so.
It's just the the
leather is winning.
There are lots of primitive ways
of making needles that can even
get through leather.
There are other types of
natural thorn that are harder,
that are sharper.
We've got a piece of antler
that we can get through.
It's very wide,
very quickly though.
So in that rich
tradition of cheating,
we've also got
some metal needles,
which even have eye holes
in them to stab right
through the leather,
and we're going to use those,
because I love metal tools.
They're great.
Poke a hole through both layers.
That stabbed through
fairly easily.
We have our sinew poked through.
Kind of near the first one.
Again, it pulls
the sinew through.
But now,
while we still have this loop,
we take the other end,
this long end,
and poke it through that hole,
and pull it all the way.
And now, when we pull
that loop down tight,
we have a stitch right in place,
and we have one
on the other side as well.
So we just need
to keep doing that,
and go down the line,
poking a hole, creating a loop,
feeding the sinew through that,
and just sewing
the whole thing shut.
[Music]
And, on my second side,
I am going to leave a gap.
Just a couple of inches
so that we can either just
tie the pipe right onto that,
or add our little pipe sleeve.
[Music]
All right. This bag has one side,
two sides, and the bottom sewn on.
I've left this gap here.
This is we're going to try
and attach our pipe.
But for the moment,
we're just going to make a mess
by putting some sawdust there,
and showing that
if I have this bag,
and I pinch the top closed,
we get a good amount of air
flying out of the exit there
so...
[Music]
Mess is everywhere.
Joseph going to keep stitching
up the bottom of that one.
I'm going to start adding
some sticks onto the top
and bottom of this,
and we're just going to make it,
so they fit pretty
nicely in there,
and just have a few stitches.
We don't need to stitch
all the way along.
I'll probably have
three to five bind points.
Whatever seems like it's necessary
to really hold it in place.
Open it, pulls an air
from the top.
Close it, pushes the air
out the bottom.
[Music]
Okay, update.
This first Bellows is
I believe complete,
and in working order.
Joseph is getting
really good progress.
He's got one more seam
to finish on his, and then
a couple sticks and handles,
but we did want to show you
where this one is.
Handles up at the top.
We've got these sticks in here.
Those are rigid.
So when we squeeze that,
it holds the whole bag top shut.
In the event that that's
not quite enough pressure,
although it seems
to work pretty well,
you can also sort
of roll it over
as you press down.
That keeps the seal even better.
These handles are there
so that as I lift it up,
I can hold it open.
That way, it doesn't draw the heat
back up through the pipe
into the Bellows.
It'd fill it up with ash,
and it would burn.
It just takes in
air from the top.
So you lift,
close, and squeeze,
and it just blows a whole bunch
of air right out.
This piece of PVC
is just fit into a hole
that I left at the bottom.
I then wrapped a lot
of this sinew down around it.
It's in there
pretty nice and tight.
Holds onto the bag,
and this size PVC just
happens to be the right size.
We might we might be able
to get some marshmallows
shooting out of this.
Let's give this a try.
I'm going to see
if I can shoot a marshmallow
into Joe's mouth.
>> Wow!
>> Slow motion replay.
[Music]
>> All right, update time.
We've got two
completed Bellows bags.
How's yours working?
>> It's functional.
>> Very cool.
You're using bamboo.
So, more realistic in terms
of things you might find
in the wilderness.
Although, it's kind of depends
on what wilderness you have.
But there's lots of different ways
you can get a pipe shape thing.
My way is PVC,
which grows on the PVC trees,
of course.
Very cool.
So now, I think the next step is
to test these out
with actual fire.
>> I think that's the next thing.
And we are going
to be doing an iron smelt.
We're going to be taking iron
ore running through the furnace,
and trying to extract
the iron out of that ore.
And these what we're going
to use to keep that fire
hot enough for hours
and hours on end.
So let's take these out
and test them out in an iron smelt.
>> Yeah, let's do it.
Our bags are made,
and we've switched
out the bamboo and PVC
that we had before for this cool
little bamboo forked shape.
That way we can have
both of the bags going
into one spot in the furnace.
This stake is here to keep it
from sliding out backwards.
So it always keeps directing
the are right where we want it.
So Joseph tell us
about our little furnace here.
>> So this furnace is called
a bloomery stack furnace,
and the purpose of it is
to transform rock, into metal.
Well, what we're going
to be doing is stuffing
it full of charcoal,
and then layering it
with charcoal and ore,
and ore is just a stone
that contains basically rust.
And so as those burn down
to the level of the air,
they're going to slowly
transform chemically into iron,
and then collect in the bottom,
and then we're going
to collect a big lump of it,
which is called a bloom.
Hence, why this
is called a bloomery.
>> So we've got our bags,
and I think we can do
a nice demonstration.
We've already got
stuff burning in here.
You can see just a thick
white smoke coming out of it.
Probably half of that
is steam as well.
But what we can do now is we
can pump with our Bellows,
and we'll watch
as this just gets
hotter and hotter,
and I think pretty quickly,
will start having flames coming
out of the top instead of smoke.
[Music]
Look at that.
Blazing flames coming
out the top.
[Music]
Now, we've basically
just smothered all
that hot fire we got.
Smoke is thick as
any smoke bomb we've ever made.
Our bag bellows are up
and running there.
Focusing a lot
of concentrated air
into our bloom furnace.
Very cool.
>> So Joseph, the next step is to actually
try and extract iron ore, right?
>> Yes, and for that,
we need iron ore.
All right,
our next video we do with Joseph
is going to be extracting iron
from Iron Ore using
our Bloom furnace
and the Bellows.
Look for that coming soon.
Guys, that's it for today.
But we've always got more
for you to see.
That box up at the top
will transport you directly
to our last video,
and you should go
check that out.
The other box will show you
what YouTube thinks you
should be watching next,
and if you're not a subscriber
yet, just hit this bomb to get in the club,
and that way you
never miss out on the fun.
Don't forget to ring the bell,
and we will see you
in the next one.
Talk to you then.